7 months ago wda was attending school in
Sudan's capital Kum when were broke out
between the Army and the paramilitary
rapid support forces she and her family
fled to the eastern city of Port
Sudan she has such high Ambitions she
wants to be a pilot she comes to me with
a notebook asking me to help her write
because she wants to go back to school I
feel so helpless to see my children's
education
disrupted since the war started in April
nearly 6 million people have been forced
from their homes hundreds of schools
away from conflict areas are unable to
open as they're being used to house
those made
homeless the total number of school a
children in Sudan is 19 million
according to the United Nations even
before the war 7 million had no access
to education the UN children's agency
says an additional 6.5 million will not
be able to go to school this year
because they're stranded in Conflict
zones raising the total number of out of
school children to 13.5 million the
agency says that puts Children at Risk
these kids the ones that were already
out of school and the ones that are now
out of school were uh they are at very
high risk of uh harmful practices and uh
risks of sexual exploitation of child's
labor child marriage child
soldiers um so this is this is extremely
high as we see it Sudan's government has
ordered schools in safe zones to open
but Sudan's teachers union says steps
need to be taken before that can
happen if the government is serious
about starting the Academic Year there
are things it needs to solve the first
are the salaries of teachers in addition
to improving the education environment
and getting a solution to integrate
displaced children because they too have
the right to
education W's mother says she hopes
schools in Port Sudan will open soon
that way her children can resume their
education and continue to work towards a
future that they dream of hia Morgan Al
jaaz Port
Sudan make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer